the biggest excuse in the world though
douchiest excuse in the world the worst
excuse in the world is you got your
prospective
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you just want to make sure my mics
on
you can keep chatting my name if you
want can you guys hear me
hello ello ello ello good no no no there
we go I hear a little more little more
little more little more that's good
what is up Singapore thank you for the
warm intro all right a lot of things I
want to cover today feel free to sit
down unless you want to stand you do you
you know I I flew from Malaysia this
morning and I was thinking about what I
wanted to speak about with this
incredible crowd and there was a lot of
different things running through my mind
but I broke them down into a couple
places I think one of the things that
I'm very feel fearful of is hypocrisy
I think it really sucks when people talk
out of both sides of their mouth and I
think one of the things that when I was
growing up in the business world that
became apparent to me is why do people
take advice from individuals who've
never done something right
I've spent a lot of time thinking about
that now it's a very interesting thing
in my mind because I used to be very 100
percent about this which is don't listen
to anybody who's never done something
but then I realized that some of the
best coaches in sports history never
played the game but understood how to
advise so that kind of took a step back
but the thing that I've realized was the
reason that my initial reaction was
don't listen to anybody who's never done
it was that for me
when I communicate I'm incapable of
being the kind of coach for a football
team if I never played it I would never
be good at that had I played baseball or
football or you know highligh or you
know whatever it may be I would have
then been able to give advice but if not
I couldn't watch film or study the game
and give advice going through this
self-awareness over the last 20 years
has allowed me to think about why over
the last two or three years my content
continues to resonate even more than
ever it's because I'm getting even more
narrow in what I talk about one of my
favorite comments on my youtube channel
or my podcast or my Instagram or
LinkedIn is when somebody says Gary Vee
you're getting boring you say the same
[ __ ] I go that's the point if you really
understand the process I think there's
way too many people talking about stuff
they don't understand or because they
think it will do well for them I only
want to talk about the stuff that I
understand because it's the only way I
can bring any value and I'm fine if
somebody feels like they got it I think
how many people here have watched my
vlog raise your hand thank you so I
think you guys know on the vlog every 20
30 episodes 50 episodes I get weird and
look at the camera and say what the [ __ ]
are you still watching this for
and I think when I think of myself in
the personalities that speaker write
books and put content I feel like I'm
the reverse I want people to hear me and
then for free and then go on and do
their thing and win instead of keeping
people in my funnel and monetize them
through courses or masterminds or other
things I think that's important and I'll
tell you why I think that it's super
important to watch who you take advice
from I I always am fascinated when
people are like Gary I've been watching
your business videos like a friend
forget about you know like somebody I've
known for 25 years I Gary but watching
his stuff lately but my uncle tells me I
should do this and the first question I
was asked is and the person's asking a
business question and I asked them well
tell me about your uncle and they're
like well he's a gym teacher at our high
school I'm like well if you want to be a
gym teacher your uncle is a tremendous
person to listen to but if you want to
build a business I think I'm better at
building businesses than your uncle and
so the reason I start this talk this way
is because I think I have a little bit
of a curveball for people that have been
following me for a little while I think
a lot of you know that one of the things
I fear the most fear is I don't want to
be a motivational speaker like I don't
like that at all I mean it I don't like
it at all because I don't think of
myself that way
but over the last year and a half the
reason I put out content that may be
more rah-rah or things of that nature is
because I've realized my God my greatest
strength the thing that I realize I can
get best advice on is I'm the byproduct
of very good parenting very good
environment which means I didn't grow up
with much so I'm not entitled very
tried-and-true 20 years of business at
this point based on work ethic and based
on giving value to the customer over
anything else and I realized that if you
here on a beautiful Saturday in the
summer for this talk that we have to
start in the strategy of where your
head's at and then I can talk to you
about the fact and this is just true
there's a reason I don't know if you
guys know this but vaynermedia is
opening an office in Singapore in the
first quarter of next year right so I'm
gonna be here a lot more going forward
over the next five years so if you see
me in a restaurant don't just stare at
me come over and say hello but I think
that the thing that's on my mind in this
market is mindset I can give you the
reasons we're opening an office in
Singapore because in Southeast Asia my
marketing strategies of buying Facebook
Ads running ads with Kol s and giving
them as much money as possible doing
podcast and LinkedIn content works
better in Singapore and Malaysia and
Indonesia than it does in America or
Europe so all the propaganda that I push
around Facebook advertising and
Instagram and all that I promise you
whether you're a lawyer or you have an
app startup where you want to sell
t-shirts I don't understand why anyone's
confused the only practical advice I
have for you right now practical black
and white is run more ads on social
media
and if you're going to run more ads on
social media to do whatever you're
trying to sell your course your sneakers
your real-estate whatever you do there's
one part that breaks in running more ads
on social media do you know how to put a
good picture or video or written word in
the ad the variable of running great ads
is the creative itself and I think too
many people don't respect the art enough
they just respect the math but from a
practical standpoint everybody here
should be running a lot more social
media you do nobody here is taking it
serious enough I'll tell you why I take
it more serious than my own religion and
I don't take it serious enough so I'm up
here and I don't take it serious enough
there is nobody here that is taking how
big of an opportunity this is serious
enough I will go back to tactics in a
minute but let me tell you why I started
my talk on one of my best at and that
should be my advice what I'm best at is
knowing that the far majority of people
in this room right now have not achieved
the success or happiness they're looking
for mainly on the back of the fact that
they value their mother or father's
opinion too much
the thing that I understand about life
and then that matters in business is you
either listen to your own voice or you
listen to somebody else's the thing that
people need to understand more than
anything is what is driving their
ambition why are you doing what you're
doing what are you trying to scratch
what are you trying to scratch are you
trying to be successful to prove to
people that said you wouldn't are you
trying to be successful because you love
the process are you doing it because you
want to buy something fancy to show
people that you're successful why do you
do what you're doing and most of all for
who what happened to me through very
good parenting is I play for myself how
many people saw rocky for the one in
Russia raise your hands I want to just
get a sense raise it high if you saw
that movie good-good amount in Rocky
four he fights a Russian guy rocky the
Russian guy talks about the pressure of
the whole Soviet Union wanting him to
beat rocky and at one point he cracks
and tells the Russian government and all
the fans [ __ ] you I'm not fighting for
you I'm fighting for me
I've always thought about that scene my
whole life
and I didn't know why until about two or
three years ago which I realized oh my
god I'm living for me I'm playing this
game for me not for anybody else and
everybody else is playing for somebody
else and that was unbelievably
liberating and I'll be very honest with
you I was very grateful for that
I think a lot of people in this room
have to go home tonight
and ask themselves who they're playing
for making your parents proud is usually
the first step to disaster I mean it I
understand that it's an interesting
angle to talk about this it's great to
want to make your parents proud but not
at the expense of your happiness and so
I've become unbelievably fascinated with
the mindset of why people do stuff and
why am I able to work 17 hours a day I'm
able to work 17 hours a day because I
love it nobody works 17 hours a day
because of any other thing because they
love it
people all the people that try to teach
you how to get rich with the least
amount of work they love the money
they love the money people love the
money a lot of people here are here to
figure out the secret for the money you
love the money you value the money I
don't value the money I value the game
my game is how good am I at this
I value the admiration I value the
admiration that's a tough thing to say a
little bit cuz it seems kind of shallow
but it's my truth I was so over loved by
my mother that when I went into the real
world I was still wanted the love and I
basically manifested with my DNA in my
environment in a way that I there's only
one reason that I'm giving you more
value than most people it's because I
want your admiration and the only way to
get real admiration is to give the most
simple as that it's not super
complicated so I'm spending a lot of
time trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
am I doing the [ __ ] am i doing in
Singapore on Saturday right now
and I realize you better be doing the
same thing because when you start
figuring out that [ __ ]
everything starts becoming a lot easier
when and listen one of the biggest
reasons I'm unbelievably drawn to
Southeast Asia is because of
entrepreneurship DNA right there's a
rawness to the entrepreneurs in the
Southeast Asian market that I really am
attracted to because I think I share
that kinship in a lot of ways but I'll
be honest with you probably right there
with it and as I get older every day
maybe even more so I'm fascinated by the
parenting culture in Southeast Asia and
the obnoxious mistakes that are being
made by parents treating their children
as products which I see playing out in
America but it's way more [ __ ] up here
but before all the kids clap and say in
their heads yeah he's right [ __ ] you mom
before you do that I just want you to
understand the most fascinating thing
about a relationship it takes two to
tango you can sit here as a 29 year old
and say wait a minute
epiphany Peter he's right I'm so mad but
you need to take responsibility for your
part you like all the nice things that
come along with pleasing your parents
there is no both ways so I am super
passionate because of this reason this
is [ __ ] crazy this is the remote
control of our lives now this is the
single most important thing in the
literally willing to rip off my arm and
give it to you then give up my phone
this is the most important and what's
happening inside of it is even crazier
everything we know is being transformed
by the platforms inside this device if
you are here today and you are not
successfully building a community on
facebook Instagram snapchat Twitter you
know LinkedIn YouTube if you're not
successful on one of the things in here
right now
no matter how much money you're making
if you are not building a community in
here you are becoming irrelevant this is
the actual world and this is becoming
secondary
and maybe you don't like it and it seems
weird it doesn't change the fact that
that's exactly what's happening and I
highly recommend to all of you that if
you are not putting in real hours in
figuring this out you are becoming
unbelievably vulnerable to whatever
ambition you sit here if you want to be
the you know Prime Minister if you want
to sell sneakers if you want to raise
money for awareness of a disease if you
want to sell your restaurant whatever it
is if you are not producing in this
environment successfully you were
becoming irrelevant and if you think
about where the world was just two or
three or four years ago in here wait to
see where it's gonna be in two or three
years this is just starting do not get
confused by the growth over the last
five years on this as if it's the end or
what have you this technology thing is
just starting and so I've been spending
a lot of times with the mix of the high
in the low the ambition and the dirt the
clouds and the dirt right why are you
doing what you're doing
and then do you know how to do it I'm
dying to know if you're doing it for
yourself or somebody else I've touched
on that then I'm dying to once you know
what you're doing for you putting in the
hours to actually do it the reason so
many of you are judging yourselves for
being lazy and not putting in the work
even though you keep hearing it it's
because you don't like what you're doing
you're doing it because you think it's
gonna make money
you're doing it because you think it's
gonna make money and so of course you're
not putting in the hours you don't like
it you deep down may even think that
it's not good you have to figure out why
you have to and then have and so why
this is a big conversation and it's
always been true
the only added extra thing for me to why
this is important on how and why is the
timing and what I'm talking about this
if this talk was happening in 1997 it
wouldn't be as important because the
internet wouldn't be at the scale that
it is today
this is about underpriced attention how
many people have ever spent time or pay
attention to real estate rich your hands
real estate okay thank you I think about
what's happening right now the way I
think about real estate
I don't trade beachfront property or
skyscrapers or homes or houses I create
attention
to me I know that everybody in here when
I look around the this room from
youngsters from this region to people
that have been around the block for a
couple of minutes maybe not from this
region when I look at all your faces the
one thing I know that I can talk about
right here that will matter to everybody
whether you have money or don't whether
your tour your ad is attention because
it is the currency that we all have to
figure out how to get to make the next
thing happen the thing that is happening
it globally in the world is about
attention the reason so much change is
happening politically around the world
is because the attention of the citizens
in the world have moved to this and the
newspaper radio television era of the
last 80 years has been disrupted which
is why you're seeing results in Malaysia
the u.s. London that are different than
what people expected they are naive and
under estimating the enormous power of
this we in this room are in a time where
we equally can take advantage of this
the amount of people sitting around
dwelling about what this is doing
instead of realising that you can do
something for yourselves with it is
fascinating to me my friends this is a
mindset game and an education game
everybody thinks education is important
you hear that propaganda all the time
right I agree I think the way education
is sold and the infrastructure around it
today is broken but I think education is
the most powerful thing in the world I'm
desperate for people in this room to be
educated on how to run Facebook ads it
is a skill it's a vocational skill if
you know how to run Facebook ads like an
expert in 2018
you will make a lot of money not a
little bit a lot yet people hear the
propaganda or they brought some ads
unsuccessfully and they quit right I
mean look how many people here by show
of hands and so far when I've asked for
hands sig more I gotta be honest with
you you've been bullshitting me
the hands have been like this I want
high hands right now how many people
here have run Facebook ads and it didn't
work raise your hands raise it high
actually stand up stand up I mean it
please stand up stand up I see a lot of
you who haven't yet stand up if you just
raised your hand stand up if you've run
Facebook ads and it didn't work I'm
gonna give you two more minutes no lying
ready
I want everybody look around look around
got it all these people that are
standing suck I'm kidding I'm kidding
sit down but it's a very important point
the reason I did that and the reason I
wanted everybody to see it is I was
standing - I have run hundreds of
thousands of dollars of ads that didn't
work but I've also run hundreds of
thousands of dollars of ads that have
worked vaynermedia has spent hundreds of
millions of dollars on ads that have
worked and hundreds of millions of
dollars that have not the ROI of
something is based on your talent to use
in
the ROI of something is based on your
talent to use it the ROI of a basketball
for me zero the ROI of a basketball for
LeBron James 1 billion dollars you have
run Facebook ads and it didn't work it
doesn't mean that Facebook Ads don't
work it means that you ran Facebook ads
that didn't work this is a very
important point here is why I stand up
here today with a man of massive regret
about one very narrow thing in business
that ironically people cheer for me for
but I boo myself
let me reenact something that happened
20 minutes ago I was being introduced
very nicely and at one point the
gentleman said and he took his family
business from for 260 million dollars
and you know what you guys did you
clapped loud let me tell you what I was
doing
I'll actually reenact it maybe it'll
hear me I was right here and he said and
he took his business from for 260
million dollars and you guys cheered
loud let me tell you what I was doing
[ __ ]
let me tell you why in 2001 to 2004
I ran Google Adwords when it was new and
most people didn't understand it a lot
of people said it wasn't working I know
I had a lot of ads that didn't work
either if this was literally 2004 I
would ask everybody here to say stand up
if you've run Google ads and it didn't
work and the same amount of people would
have stood up okay what I know about
Wine Library was between email and
Google AdWords that was a dominant
reason that I was able to take my dad's
business that didn't have a lot of money
and exploded because it was right it's
the same reason the Amazon is gonna be
one of the biggest companies in the
world because they were the biggest
advertiser on Google AdWords during that
era I sit behind stage while I get
clapped for 260 and my brain says it
should have been four to 250 if I was
good enough and went hard enough and
took more money and tried harder and
slept less and went harder it would have
been four to 250 I stand here today
knowing that's exactly what's happening
right now on Facebook and Instagram that
every person in this room is gonna
remember this part of the speech in
seven years and look back and
ninety-eight percent of you because
you're not gonna do it are gonna say I
[ __ ] up I should have listened to him
I mean that I mean it I know it because
even I am not spending enough I'm
spending so much I have a 30 person team
I'm spending hundreds of thousands of
dollars and I should be spending
millions
so please my friends understand the
following if you are not producing
content for Facebook for YouTube for
LinkedIn depending on your business
depending on who you're trying to reach
if you do not understand that pictures
videos and written words and audio for
seven to eight apps on the phone is the
world then you are vulnerable if you do
not understand that we are living in a
special moment of time because let me
tell you what's about to happen over the
next five years vaynermedia is about to
become one of the biggest marketing
companies in the world because coca-cola
and BMW and GE and sa P and Nike are all
gonna hire us over the next five years
and I'm gonna take five hundred million
dollars from television and I'm gonna
put it into Facebook Facebook is a
marketplace so when Facebook you have to
understand you're all very smart
Facebook and Instagram if you want to
reach somebody that lives in Singapore
who makes $100,000 a year and I want to
get in front of you it's gonna be in
your feed either you're gonna be there
or Nikes gonna be there who has more
money they're gonna bid you up and now
it costs six dollars to get a thousand
in front of a thousand people of which
only thirteen look because we all go
fast I got it but it's still six dollars
for 13 people
but in four years it's gonna be $38 for
a thousand and only six are gonna look
at it my friends this is a moment in
time on social networks on a mobile
device that is unparalleled in the
history of marketing better than early
television better than early internet
you know why everybody's on it everybody
is on it from six years old to 96 years
old there are 65 year old men sending
text emojis right now everybody your
grandparents are on it this has happened
please stop [ __ ] around please take
this seriously please produce content on
these platforms with everything you have
how many people are being successful
right now with social media marketing
and advertising raise your hands raise
your hands high how many people there
are the people that are most worried
about I mean it the success is
disguising how good it is I'm more
worried about me than the 90% that
didn't raise their hand because I've
done the hard work to figure out it's
good and yet I'm still not eating enough
of it
how many people here are in the personal
brand business the content they put out
is them as a human being raise your
hands raise your hands high I just need
to know one of the biggest things that I
want to spend some time on is this
category and I think a lot more of you
should be in it I think everybody here
should be putting out content as a
person and the reason they don't how
many people here work for somebody raise
your hands
okay so that group I understand they're
not in full control so maybe it would be
uncomfortable for them to put out
content because they're worried about
the boss makes sense for everybody else
every person should be producing content
yet of the people that are left that
didn't raise their hand only about 10%
of that audience based on what I just
looked at is putting out content the
biggest reason most people are putting
out content is they're worried about
other people's opinions of their content
there's a lot of people here who stopped
posting on social media because one
anonymous person said that they were
ugly
we're living in a time when this is
offering us the greatest personal
opportunity for upside and the reason
you're not taking advantage of it is
because somebody anonymous in the
Philippines left a comment and said you
were stupid that [ __ ] with me and I
need you to understand it and it goes
back to the biggest thing that I started
with which is who are you doing this for
and are you allowing the fact that most
people in the world will live their
entire life valuing somebody else's
opinion of themselves more than their
own opinion about themselves baffles me
I I will spend the rest of my life
talking about this and putting pressure
on this conversation cut is
fundamentally the unlock it is I'm
watching humans do everything from
buying clothes to buying homes with
extra bedrooms that they don't need to a
million other things that look like that
literally trying to keep up with the
Joneses I don't know who these Joneses
are but I'm gonna [ __ ] kill them I
mean it I want to find the Joneses and I
want to assassinate the Joneses because
the amount of time and energy you spend
keeping up with the Joneses is
staggering the respect that parents in
America and Asia have for each other is
the reason they're so bad at parenting
they care about their friends opinions
about their kids more than they care
about their kids happiness
it's crazy
[Applause]
and so that's what's breaking down for
me everyone that's what's kind of top of
mind
I'm staggered and taken aback by the
disproportionate abundance that we have
I can't believe how much an opportunity
you actually have I can't believe how
simple I mean kids with no experience
who just listened carefully a month in
which is no time at all
are feeling the benefits of selling
stuff on these platforms that only
speaks to me of how easy it is there's
so much abundance there's so much
abundance and there's P you know another
reason another reason people in this
room are not running their business
through Facebook right now in Singapore
let's use that is because they have an
opinion about Facebook itself you have
an opinion socially about the phone and
you're letting that opinion socially
dictate your business your opinion on
what kids should be doing on their phone
is dictating how you're thinking about
your business or the fact that you don't
like seeing ads means you're not running
them because you don't like it making
decisions on you a focus group of one
instead of letting the market make
decisions is a Norma's is an enormous
mistake and I see it every single day I
love when people like Gary Gary I hurt
your talk but me and my friends we don't
use Facebook I go that's nice Carol but
three [ __ ] billion people do my
friends the data is obvious the market
is obvious what's not obvious to me is
why you're not taking advantage of it
what's not obvious to me is the majority
of people here are here because they
consume my content you decided to come
on a Saturday you're watching the
content this is literally like I don't
know what you thought I was gonna talk
about up here like you know what's
coming out of my mouth you know exactly
what the [ __ ] I'm gonna talk about and I
what's interesting to me is why I have
to do it because I know that maybe you
needed to see it live maybe
[Laughter]
maybe something happened yesterday in
your business the reason I continue to
do what I do is because I know it's 100%
working and I don't know enough about
you to know which time why do you think
I do audio and video and written I don't
know how you like to consume content in
human form in a phone in audio in video
in a motivational quote on Instagram in
a [ __ ] ridiculous snap I don't know
how you want it but what I'm gonna give
you is very basic get your mental [ __ ]
together and [ __ ] do Facebook and
Instagram it's that basic and so listen
I really appreciate that moment because
it's the most kind of honest moment mean
you just had I literally don't have
anything else like like I can talk up
here for next 11 hours and I'm happy to
but if you're asking me what my ambition
is when I fly across the world it's that
in nine months I get a DM or an email
from one of you that says hey and by the
way this is how my life is so I already
know what it looks like hey Gary
Sally here I saw you in Singapore in
July a little bit about me I sell
flowers I have a flower shop and my
internet business was doing okay I've
been listening to your podcast for two
and a half years before you came to
Singapore it was the first time that I
heard you live for some reason I finally
really listened and I started making
fifteen pictures and twenty written
terms and nine videos a week instead of
one and you'll never believe this Gary
but my business has gone from 1.3
million to 6.2 million
I just wanted to email you and thank you
I reply no [ __ ] Sally good for you
that is why I'm here
because that feeling of actually
changing somebody's life for in essence
free is a [ __ ] feeling and a half and
so I'm asking now I'm gonna be selfish
you don't want to make yourself happy
for you because you've got fucked-up
parents fine do it for me click click
and it's really interesting why I asked
you this I had an epiphany 40 years ago
as somebody depending how many people
used to watch the wine show anybody
thank you dude there we go so like over
the last four years I've gotten my
health in much better shape and you'll
never believe why for the first 38 years
of my life I didn't do it for me I'm not
good at doing things for me somewhere on
a flight from Houston to New York I
figured out that I'm good at being
accountable to you I'm a good boss I'm a
good leader I'm a good brother I'm good
at that so I realized wait a minute if I
hire somebody full-time who's always
with me I'm not gonna want to let him
down and I literally figured out my
health by paying somebody $100,000 a
year just to travel and follow me around
and be my babysitter and that I didn't
want to let them down is why I am now in
good shape when I said to you if you
don't want to do it for you
do it for me I'm not kidding you need to
figure out your hack if you are not
happy or satisfied in this room right
now professionally which is usually
because it's emotional if you're not in
that place what you tend to do you know
what's so fascinating to me about this
world of speakers and masterminds and
courses and books and things of that
nature
I just want to solve the problem and
move on and never see you again I mean
it it's like the business of Medicine
the answer is very simple you're not in
the right place in your head you're not
but most people take advantage of that
and keep you on the drug forever
I just want to operate on you I just
want to look you in the face and call
out your [ __ ]
yesterday Malaysia's some young man said
Gary I have a problem I do I'm too good
at too many things so I can't pick one
thing because I don't know which one to
pick how do I do that how what do I do
and I said well first of all you realize
that the biggest excuse in the world
though douchiest excuse in the world the
worst excuse in the world is I'm too
good at too many things because what
you're actually saying is I actually
don't want to do anything and I want to
paint a facade to everybody that I'm
good at things or a perfectionist
Gary the reason I'm not done with my
project is I'm a perfectionist excuse
excuse excuse you need to figure out why
you're making excuses
I'll save you time you value somebody
else's opinion more than you value your
own
you have to figure out how to fix that
yesterday
you have to figure out how to fix that
yesterday it is the number one cancer in
our minds in the world you have to
figure out and if you're sitting here
right now and saying okay that's fine
Gary but the problem is the voice that
tells me I'm not good most is my own
voice in my own head to me right I want
to tell the people in this room that
have that issue that somebody put that
voice in your head not you this is a
very important point here's why if I can
get you past that hurdle you'll start
doing if I can get you past the hurdle
of what's going on your head you'll
start doing if you start doing at this
moment the Facebook and Instagram thing
you will see results
I'm just curious what's holding you back
I think a lot of people are held back
because they're scared to fail in front
of everybody because if they fail then
it's their loss the reason
entrepreneurship is hard is you have
nobody to blame you know who's an
employee raise your hands you know why
it's awesome to be an employee you get
to blame somebody else
the reason it sucks to be an
entrepreneur right now it's cool to be
an entrepreneur because there's so much
money in the system and everybody's
raising capital and you put entrepreneur
in your Instagram account and everything
looks great right
the problem is 98% of people are gonna
lose and when that loss happens do they
have the mental strength to deal with
the judgment your inability to deal with
judgment the secrets you're hiding
inside yourself that you don't want
other people to know is the reason
you're not on the offense I need you to
cleanse it and I need you to go in the
offense and I'll tell you why I'm
passionate about it now and I promise
you I'm making a prediction which I hate
to do I will not be talking about this
in six years because I'll still want you
to fix your head but the actions won't
be as opportunistic as they are right
now scale underpriced the tension comes
along in cycles when the television took
the attention from the radio from the
50s and 60s and 70s commercials were
underpriced that's why there's so much
money in commercials now
but it's not anymore for the rest of
your life your friends family kids
grandkids are gonna ask you about this
era of influencers and startups and why
it happened what was it like when all
these things were happening and I don't
want you sitting there with regret that
you didn't take advantage of it just
like I have regret in the back room that
I didn't fully take advantage of Google
I took advantage of it I did okay
especially for my family but I didn't do
what I could have done and that is what
hurts I know it's happening right now I
know we're sitting through the single
biggest scaled attention platform the
internet mobile devices social networks
on the mobile devices right now I know
that every single person here can get
something from it and I'm trying to
figure out why you're not doing it
because I've told it to you [ __ ]
eight thousand times right you've heard
it who here has heard me say things like
this before even once in their lives
raise your hands I need it I need to
know why the [ __ ] you're not spending
money on Facebook Ads I need to know and
what I know is that some of the heady
[ __ ] that I was talking about in this
talk
the judgment of others the fear of
failing in front of everybody you are
acting like an entrepreneur but in your
heart you know you're not good at it and
you know you're inevitably gonna fail
and you don't want to deal with the
ramifications of that loss so you're
completely half pregnant right now
you're acting like an entrepreneur
you're not doing anything and it's just
gonna take some time and inevitably
you're gonna start working somewhere in
six years I don't want that for you I
want one thing for you health the second
thing I want for you self-awareness do
you know who the [ __ ] you are do you
know what you're good at these are
important topics my friends younger old
you know who I fear the most
everybody in here who's over 3540 years
old because they start thinking about
it's too late like I don't have enough
time or I already [ __ ] you're gonna
live so much longer you're gonna live so
much longer and so I I am desperate to
understand where you're at with your
head on this and why you're not
attacking it because I know flat-out
that most of the [ __ ] you hear every day
today tomorrow is just a band-aid to
your [ __ ]
and that you really gotta figure out
what the [ __ ] going on inside because
you know what to do the question is why
are you not doing it my friends the math
around becoming a human being in current
scientists is 400 trillion to 1 the odds
of you sitting here wearing those
awesome green pants are 400 trillion to
1 there is nothing that will ever happen
in your life that is more remarkable
than the fact that you have a [ __ ]
life
so since everybody here is a [ __ ]
miracle wouldn't it be a good idea to do
something with it like isn't it time now
to finally get rid of the poison in your
[ __ ] head and stop worrying about
other people's judgement on you let me
tell you the best part about not giving
a [ __ ] about other people it's not like
the freedom it's how you get there do
you know how I got to a place of not
giving a [ __ ]
I realized everybody else suck that [ __ ]
too like so you think your mom's so
special
she's got shortcoming somewhere else so
your older brothers great at [ __ ]
school and makes 4 million dollars a
year he's probably a dick face
please please please use this keynote as
the seed to figure out why you're acting
for other people and not yourself
because the second you do the second you
actually [ __ ] make this decision that
I'm putting a lot of pressure on you
you'll actually start doing the things
you know why I do think do you know how
hard it was for me to have d-roc follow
me three years ago nobody was running
around the world with a person following
them
the only vloggers were doing at first
person I did it because I knew it was
right and where the world was going but
the only reason I really did it is cuz I
didn't care that you judged me that I
was a douche or a jerk for having
somebody follow me I could never do all
the things that I do if I allowed you to
judge me everybody told me the internet
was a fad everybody told me email wasn't
gonna work everybody told me YouTube was
stupid Twitter was really stupid
everybody told me not to put all my
money into Facebook every good thing
that has ever happened to me everybody
told me was stupid so why the [ __ ] am I
gonna listen to anybody and I promise
you you're living that same life to do
the [ __ ] thing that you want to do
stop [ __ ] listening to other people
start executing get your head right and
really get perspective
you're a [ __ ] miracle do something
with it I [ __ ] love you Singapore
stop [ __ ] around and take advantage
of your life thank you ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
do something do something
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah amazing that amazing
[Applause]
reversing
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
see guys thank you do something
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]